beaucoup public sénat en partenariat
avec l' afp les échos radio classique
présente
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
benjamin griveaux le porte parole du
gouvernement est l'invité de l'épreuve
de vérité bonsoir soi et merci d'être
avec nous à ce rendez vous donc de
public sénat avec la fp avec les échos
et avec radio classique médias
représentés ce soir par lucile bréau et
marques bn bonsoir il y à bientôt un an
emmanuel macron était donc élu
aujourd'hui les interrogations se font
pressantes sur les tensions sociales et
vous répondrai donc au cours de cette
émission à trois grandes questions 1 et
ce par crainte qu emmanuel macron lance
la bataille de la com avec pas moins de
deux émissions télé dans la semaine deux
le pouvoir oublie-t-il les classes
populaires c'est un reproche qui vient
de la gauche comme de la droite enfin 3
y at il du tangage dans la majorité
autour de la réforme des institutions ou
encore du projet de loi asile
immigration mais d'abord benjamin
griveaux une toute première question
d'actualité
[Musique]
la france fait partie des pays qui ont
demandé ce soir la réunion en urgence du
conseil de sécurité de l'onu après les
nouvelles frappes chimiques épouvantable
en syrie est ce que pour paris la
responsabilité du régime de bachar
el-assad et de ses alliés ne fait
désormais aucun doute vous le savez le
président de la république a échangé
suite à ce qu'il est intervenu à la
route à tout qu'est né vous rappeliez le
caractère épouvantable et abominable des
images que nous avons vues il n'agirait
que le présent trump cette nuit ils ont
convenu de donner instruction à leurs
équipes respectives de pouvoir
approfondir les échanges dans les
prochains jours et ce soir se réunit à
21h heure de paris une importante
réunion du conseil de sécurité des
nations unies qui permettra espérons de
prendre des décisions la ligne rouge il
l'a marqué dès le mois de février et il
a rappelé que si l'utilisation d'armes
chimiques étaient avérées bien cela
appelle rennes riposte vous avez vous
dis toujours si donc il ya une réunion
du conseil de sécurité des nations unies
qui se tient ce soir à 21h heure de
paris nous en saurons plus elles chutent
ce qu'est ce que vous avez des preuves
aujourd'hui effectivement emmanuel
macron il a toujours dit nous
n'interviendrons que si nous avons des
preuves qu'il ya une utilisation d'armes
chimiques est ce qu'aujourd'hui on est
en mesure d'apporter d'apporter ça il
faut que tous les moyens qu'ils puissent
être mises en oeuvre pour déterminer si
oui ou non ils à usage d'armes chimiques
puissent être mises à la disposition des
enquêteurs
à ce stade les informations dont nous
sommes en notre possession confirme a
priori l'utilisation d'armes chimiques
adacore donc on s'oriente donc vers
l'utilisation de la force à nouveau
réplique à nouveau cité cette ligne
rouge s'avérait être franchie il y
aurait une riposte comme le président de
la république s'y est engagé à maintes
reprises donald trump l'avait déjà fait
une fois de bombarder le régime syrien
après un incident similaire est ce que
c'est une bonne stratégie finalement les
effets avait été un incident c'est la
violation caractérisée du droit
international et notamment de
l'interdiction d'utilisation d'armes
chimiques et en particulier sur des
populations civiles les images
on a vu hier soir en atteste village
contre des civils des femmes des enfants
jeunes adolescents et donc il ya déjà eu
des frappes vous le rappeliez présentera
m'avait frappé année dernière si cela
devait s'avérer à nouveau être le cas il
faudra frapper
est-ce que c'est cela qui permet de
sortir du conflit terrible que connaît
la série depuis maintenant sept années
sans doute pas mais si cela permet de
mettre à mal des installations qui
permettent de produire des armes
chimiques ou de lait militarisé ou de
les utiliser bien c'est une semaine où
tu donnes des six mais ce qu'israël a
proposé à la france d'être associés aux
frappes de la nuit dernière justement
contre des interventions militaires je
ne dispose pas de cette information
d'accord et le ton monte très fort on le
voit du côté russe à moscou on met en
garde contre un risque pour la paix
mondiale en cas d'intervention
occidentale en syrie ce que vous tenez
compte de ce contexte très tendu est ce
que vous êtes
est ce que la france serait prête à
s'engager dans ce contexte la france est
prête à s'engager simplement sur le
respect du droit international comme le
présent la république l'a toujours
appelé dans toutes ses interventions
encore mois de septembre dernier
l'assemblée générale des nations unies
c'est le multilatéralisme et le respect
du droit international qui doit primer
toute position et toute décision
politique en matière internationale pour
notre pays alors encore une question
d'ordre international à l'occasion de la
visite à paris du prince héritier
saoudien mohammed bin salman des ong
dénoncent aujourd'hui les ventes d'armes
à ryad possiblement d'ailleurs utilisé
voyez au yémen qu'est ce que vous leur
répondez leur dire d'abord que lorsque
nous recevons des dignitaires étrangers
l'intérêt un interdit d'avoir des
discussions avec eux sur différents
sujets que ce soit des droits de l'homme
ou autres n'ont encaissé que la
partenaire commercial important pour la
france qu'il ya une industrie en france
importante avec des milliers d'emplois à
la clé sur cette industrie particulière
qui est l'industrie de l'armement
mais cela nous commande quand même de ne
pas non plus fermer les yeux il y a des
accords internationaux des engagements
fermes les yeux à nouveau mais que sur
l'utilisation de la diplomatie
économique pour restaurer l influence de
la france dans certaines zones du monde
et bien c'est un élément important de
notre
diplomatie et que notre industrie a
aussi besoin de pouvoir trouver des
débouchés sur ces marchés
c'est donc les gendarmes c'est un motif
de fierté d'efficacité d'influencé et
puis c'est un outil économique important
à nouveau tout départ à qui vous vendez
les armes
la manière dont elles peuvent être
utilisées par la suite c est donc en
l'occurrence là il ya un intérêt clair
pour l'industrie française de pouvoir
procéder à ces échanges de nature
commerciale avec l'arabie saoudite la
suite de l'épreuve de vérité tout de
suite avec la question que vous posez
lucile bréau du style alors elle est
assez simple emmanuel macron va être
très présent sur nos écrans cette
semaine sur tf1 jeudi le 13 heures de
jean pierre pernaut sur bfm télé
dimanche deux heures de direct
est-ce que c'est par crainte finalement
de ce qui se passe aujourd'hui dans la
rue dans le pays qu emmanuel macron
lance cette bataille de la communication
c'est pas une bataille de la
communication vous savez le présent de
la république
il a parlé aux français depuis le
premier jour de son mandat alors pas
toujours sur des plateaux télé mais il
fait beaucoup de déplacements et quand
il se déplace il ya pas d cordon de
sécurité autour de lui qui l'empêchent
d'avoir des échanges on l'a vu au seul
en agriculture on l'a vu encore la
semaine dernière lorsqu'il était à rouen
on l'a vu à clermont ferrand on l'a vu
dans beaucoup d'endroits où il a un
contact direct avec les français et il
souhaite
il a souhaité pouvoir et bien avoir
cette relation directe cette semaine à
deux reprises dans des formats
différents et donc avec des sans doute
eu des auditoires différents dans le 13
heures de jean pierre pernaut et puis
dans un échange avec mediapart et bfm
vos confrères dimanche soir ça n'est pas
une bataille de la communication
présente la république
il est là pour pouvoir parler aux
français librement et pouvoir expliquer
en permanence la politique que nous
conduisons et sur laquelle nous avons
été élus le monde dit aujourd'hui son
silence était devenu assourdissant est
ce qu'il y avait vraiment une prise de
conscience à avoir désire maintenant le
chef de l'état doit parler on a vu qu
edouard philippe est monté au front
énormément c'est ce qui est assez
troublant c'est que quand il parle pas
c'est la déconnexion et quand il parle
c'est de la communication alors moi je
suis un peu voyez circonspect sur que ya
pas de bons choix
donc là il fait le choix de s'exprimer
sur les plateaux très bien mais
il s'exprime régulièrement et à maintes
reprises il l'a déjà fait en irak mais
là il ya une interview les déplacements
là il ya une intention particulière coup
sur coup il ya un travail d'explication
et l agression qui est cuite nécessaire
c'est toujours nécessaire d'expliquer
des choses est de faire de la pédagogie
nous n'en avons jamais fait ça c est ce
que c'est du moins une flat fin
définitive de ce qu'on a appelé laird
jupitérienne où le président n'avait pas
trop envie de parler dans les médias où
il essayait de travailler sur d'autres
moyens d'expression de devenir plus
présidentiel est ce que la finalement
c'est d'une façon dire on a besoin de
cet exercice je sais pas si on a besoin
de cet exercice mais il a toujours eu
pour principe de s'exprimer sur des
supports différents et il l'a fait quand
il était candidat dans le cadre de
l'élection présentielle en allant sur
des supports assez inédit pour des
campagnes électorales disons
traditionnelle et donc je crois que il
veut maintenir cette relation qu'il a su
nouer avec les français à travers des
supports médiatiques qui sont très
différents entre 1 13 heures et puis un
exercice de deux heures avec deux
intervieweurs ce sont des formats
différents auprès d'audiences
différentes je crois avec ça qu'ils
souhaitent pouvoir renouer lancia de la
campagne présidentielle s'il ne parle
pas par crainte est ce que vous
qualifiez aujourd'hui le climat de
l'exécutif avec les grèves les facs la
sncf bien sûr on va en parler
est ce que vous qualifiez ce climat de
seraing pour l'exécutif mais il savait
nous on est extrêmement concentré sur la
tâche que nous a confié le président de
la république à savoir transformer le
pays et c'est au fond le mandat que nous
ont confié des français donc on est
serein on est à l'écouté on est attentif
on n'est pas sourd à ce que disent les
cheminots ce que disent d'ailleurs de
manière très différente
et personne dans les hôpital ce que
disent quelques très minoritaire
groupuscules dans les universités qui
d'ailleurs bien ce ne sont pas des
étudiants donc nous faisons la
différence entre des revendications qui
ont des natures très les hétérogènes et
des modes d'expression très hétérogène
mais on travaille et d'ailleurs la
ministre des transports sur le cas de la
sncf reçoit des organisations syndicales
travail le débat parlementaire va
s'ouvrir cette semaine sur le nouveau
pacte ferroviaire donc nous procédons
par étape
on écoute on est attentif et puis on
tranche
alors voyons les résultats du sondage
opinionway pour l'épreuve de vérité vous
allez découvrir les résultats
54% des français considèrent que la
grève des cheminots n'est pas justifiée
45 % la jugent justifiée c'est quand
même un chiffre élevé même s'il est
minoritaire deuxième question 56 %
approuvent la fermeté du gouvernement
alors posez peut-être trouvé des
encouragements dans ses résultats mais
écouter écouter ce que dit le
spécialiste des relations sociales
bernard vivier bien il vous interpelle
monsieur le porte-parole
réformer la sncf c'est remettre à flot
ou une entreprise qui tente déficit
grave et chronique
mais réformer la sncf c'est aussi mettre
en avant tous les atouts de la sncf
la fierté cheminote ces derniers
éléments ne sont pas suffisamment mis en
valeur est ce que la communication du
gouvernement est bien au rendez vous de
ce que les cheminots attendent de
considération pour leur métier et
l'opinion publique pour leur attachement
aux rails un élément du patrimoine
français alors par définition jeu juste
je réponds aux enquêtes puis après
monsieur viguier mais sur les enquêtes
on ne m'a jamais pris nos décisions on
n'a jamais fait nos grands arbitrages en
ayant les yeux rivés sur les enquêtes ou
qu'elles soient bonnes ou pas bonne
qu'elle valide ou pas c'est pas ça notre
boussole votre boussole et en
l'occurrence sur la question de la sncf
c'est d'avoir demain une grande
entreprise publique française qui soit
en capacité est bien de faire face à une
ouverture à la concurrence que nous
n'avons pas décidé qui a été décidé dans
le quinquennat précédent et d'avoir
surtout un service public fort vert qui
rendent des services à moindre coût et
avec une meilleure qualité de service
pour les usagers
et moi je le dis nous n'avons jamais
attaqué les cheminots personne ne peut
considérer raisonnablement que la dette
de la sncf c'est la responsabilité
exclusive des cheminots personne n'a
jamais dit ça au gouvernement je vous
mets au défi de trouver l'expression
d'un ministre ou d'un membre du
gouvernement allant en ce sens nous on a
le plus grand respect pour les cheminots
mais ce qu'on veut dire c'est que si on
ne procède pas à cette transformation de
la sncf il ya un risque pour
l'entreprise publique et ne ne pas être
en capacité de faire face
une fois la concurrence ouverte créée là
le rif que là vous avez entendu c'est de
négliger les corps intermédiaires mais
on avait lors laurent berger de la cfdt
avec
il ya quelques temps qu'il disait
justement qu'avec macro n'y a pas de
négociation c'est pas vrai rien à voir
il ya des négociations on prenait les
ordonnances sur le marché du travail est
plus 300 heures de négociations l'été
dernier auprès de muriel pénicaud
là nous avons commencé avec les assises
de la mobilité à l'automne dernier pour
parler du ferroviaire
ensuite il ya eu le fameux rapport
spinetta est depuis rapport smit a des
dizaines de réunions avec la ministre
des transports qui ont par exemple
permis de déposer à l'assemblée
nationale des amendements sur
l'ouverture à la concurrence donc il ya
des sujets à quelle date cela peut
entrer en vigueur sur la question du
statut aussi sur la question de la
gouvernance
donc tout ça se discute c'est normal que
ça suscite des inquiétudes et
interrogations des angoisses c'est
parfaitement légitime mais elles sont
aussi le fruit d' absence de choix des
vingt dernières années sur des sujets
aussi long au cur ans que le rail
français
mais justement tout de même escape à un
problème de méthode est ce que vous
l'avez suffisamment bien expliquer cette
réforme qui arrive par exemple on parle
beaucoup du statut du cheminot
qu'est ce que ça apporte aux usagers
finalement la fin de ce statut mais la
fin du statut est je le rappelle pas
pour les cheminots qui sont sous statut
toutes les personnes qui aujourd'hui ont
été embauchés sous statut le resteront
voyez nous on n'est pas question de
rompre le contrat moral passé entre
l'état et l'entreprise publique sncf et
les cheminots
c'est normal ce serait pas d'ailleurs
une bonne manière de procéder
mais en revanche considéré qu'il faut
mettre sans doute un peu plus d'agilité
et de souplesse donc pour les
recrutements à venir n'est pas une
mauvaise chose
vous avez aujourd'hui des situations
aberrantes vous avez des jeunes qui sont
bien qualifiées qui voudraient pouvoir
rentrer et qui parce qu'ils ont d'abord
une expérience professionnelle
si vous les mettez sous statut ils vont
rentrer à des salaires inférieurs un
niveau inférieur que ce qu'ils ont déjà
pu prouver dans d'autres fonctions
donc on voit bien qu'il ya des rigidités
interne au statut on ne le remet pas en
cause pour les gens qui sont sous statut
mais en revanche pour les nouveaux
recrutés ce sera le cas et il ya déjà à
la sncf 25 à 30% des personnes qui ne
sont pas sous statut et où ça fonctionne
vous parlez de la dette est ce que
pour l'instant le gouvernement a déjà
dit on verra comment se passe la
concertation et on décidera ensuite
quelle partie de la dette ou si on
reprend une partie de l'aide est ce
qu'il faudrait pas aujourd'hui comme
signal vis-à-vis des cheminots dire on
se soucie de l'avenir l'entreprise
on est prêt à prendre une partie et le
faire dès à présent mais on a dit et
promis cela dit dès ses premières
interventions il ya quelques semaines la
question de la dette
elle est évidemment importante et l'état
prendra sa part de responsabilité mais
il faut aussi que l'entreprise ait donné
des gages sur sa capacité à se
transformer à se réformer parce que une
entreprise publique aujourd'hui perd 3
milliards d'euros par an et dans
laquelle on avait quand même 14
milliards d'euros par an c'est autant
que la police et la gendarmerie réunis
une entreprise qui perd 3 milliard
d'euros par an si on éponge la dette
mais qu'on fait pas les transformations
dans l'entreprise elle continuera à
perdre 3 milliards d'euros par an et la
dette qu'on aurait éponger elle se
reconstituera très vite donc l'objectif
c'est d'avoir d'abord une question sur
comment est ce que l'entreprise se
transforme en interne pour permettre la
de minimiser le poids de la dette et de
faire les transformations nécessaires et
en effet l'état prendra ses
responsabilités mais ça ça a été dit et
rap dévoyé par ministre amar est temps
de dire que au moins vous prendrez une
partie quoi qu'il arrive tu es les
discussions vont se poursuivre à nouveau
cette semaine auprès d'élisabeth bornes
la ministre des transports et je ne
doute pas que cette question mais elle
elle a été directrice de la stratégie de
la sncf vous avez dit des
responsabilités effectivement qui
remonte au passé à la poste de
responsabilité est la voie la ministre
aujourd'hui elle l'a été il ya déjà
longtemps je vous le dis dans les deux
villes l'instabilité vis-à-vis de la
sncf
les gouvernements successifs depuis 25
ans qui sont responsables de l'état de
la sncf et des choix qui ont été faits
quand on a préféré les lignes à grande
vitesse parfois pour faire plaisir à
certains élus ou pour satisfaire
certains élus locaux et c'était pas
peut-être les meilleurs choix qui ont
toujours été faits au détriment des
lignes du quotidien on se retrouve
aujourd'hui avec deux cent mille
voyageurs tgv par jour où les lignes tgv
fonctionne très bien fait pareil on en
deux heures par et l'île en une heure et
marseillan 3 c'est formidable mais avec
des lignes du quotidien qui transporte
quatre millions 200 mille de nos
concitoyens chaque jour qui ne
fonctionne pas nous c'est sur ces lignes
du quotidien qu'on veut mettre le paquet
notre dame des landes maintenant on a eu
une intervention musclée ce matin qu'ils
étaient
attendu fin de la trêve hivernale ça
veut dire le début des expulsions est ce
que ces expulsions elles valent
avertissement pour ceux qui seraient
tentés de s'installer ailleurs on
connaît le cas de ben hur qui va un
moment donné aussi se poser est ce que
ça vaut avertissement est ce que c'est
une méthode qu'il faut dupliquer à un
moment donné sur les autres potentiels
c'est simplement le respect de l'état de
droit vous avez des personnes qui
occupent des terrains de manière
illégale puisqu'ils n'ont pas de titre
de propriété et qui sont là très
clairement pour en découdre avec les
forces de l'ordre
et ça fait dix ans que ça dure il y
avait déjà une opération qui avait tenté
il ya quelques années qui n'avait pas
été couronné de succès atteint 12,2
féminisme est bien là nous faisons
simplement respecter l'état de droit
c'est ce à quoi nous nous étions engagés
lorsque nous avons pris la décision de
ne pas réaliser l'aéroport de notre dame
des landes mais de lui préférer
l'extension de l'aéroport de
nantes-atlantique samouni nous ferions
la concertation qu'on respecterait la
trêve hivernale parce que nous nous
inscrivons strictement dans l'état de
droit une fois la trêve hivernale
terminé il est normal de pouvoir
procéder à ces expulsions de terrain qui
sont occupées je le rappelle de manière
parfaitement illégal alors il ya une
autre intervention qui a suscité la
polémique aujourd'hui c'est
l'intervention des forces de l'ordre
dans la fac de nanterre est ce que c'est
une stratégie qui ce que vous défendez
est ce que ce n'est pas là les trop loin
alors que le mouvement dans les
universités était récent enfin
mais le mouvement dans les universités
n'est bien souvent pas le fait des
étudiants eux mêmes mais deux personnes
souvent extérieurs à l'université et
l'université ne doit pas être le lieu
d'expression d'un troisième tour de
l'élection présidentielle ou de
contestation qui n'ont rien à voir avec
l'avenir des étudiants
rien rien à voir avec la réforme porté
sur l'enseignement supérieur et bien
souvent sont le réceptacle de
contestation finalement de la politique
on est par le président de la république
il ya des mods pour contester la
politique on les doit à présent la
république manifestations les grèves on
le voit et ils sont parfaitement
légitimes mais ça ne tenez ça n'est pas
le lieu à l'université d'être bien le
réceptacle d'autres luttent donc ça peut
se faire ailleurs ça peut se faire dans
d'autres facultés 6 mai n'ont pas
l'univers à nouveau ce est
instrumentalisée par des factions très
politisée et bien sous la question là
en dix ans policière dont l'intervention
policière par exemple à tolbiac coup le
président on dit qu'il est en train de
voir se constituer une zac universitaire
dans son établissement il n'y a pas de
zone de non droit dans notre pays
mais s'il faut envoyer les crs pour
autant dans les facs pour les déplacés
valu au cas par cas mais il n'y a pas de
zone de non droit dans notre pays est à
nouveau ce qu' il également et souvent
au détriment des étudiants parce que je
rappelle que dans les universités vous
avez 40 à 50 mille étudiants
il vous en avait 150 qui bloquent un
amphi et quand je dis 150 c'est souvent
bien bien minoritairement des étudiants
eux mêmes
ça n'est pas logique il faut que les
examens puissent se faire en bonne
condition
la mise et en semences perrin a pris
l'engagement que ce serait le cas et que
les étudiants puissent suivre les cours
le plus normalement du monde ou parce
que c'est l'immense majorité d'entre eux
bien ce qu'il souhaite vous demander le
respect de l'état de droit qu'est ce que
vous pensez des profs des des anciens
dans les facs qui refusent de siéger
dans les commissions d'examen des
dossiers des bacheliers 1 dans le cadre
du nouveau parcours super ce qu'ils sont
donc là hors la loi je considère que
quand on est un fonctionnaire
la première des règles c'est de
respecter la loi donc ça appelle des
sanctions
en tout cas la première des règles quand
on est un fonctionnaire de la république
c'est de respecter la loi et le droit la
suite de l'épreuve de vérité avec la
question que va vous poser maintenant
marques prêts elle
[Musique]
alors monsieur mais ça c'est un autre
reproche comme le disait michel qu'on
entend à droite comme à gauche peut-être
un peu plus à gauche le gouvernement
oublierait oublier les classes
populaires il oublie à droite on entend
plutôt les classes rurales la france
périphérique et à gauche les gens
modestes qui voit l'impôt sur la fortune
la réforme l'impôt sur la fortune etc
qu'est ce que vous leur répondez je
réponds que souvent depuis 20 ou 25 ans
à gauche comme à droite on considérait
qu'on faisait une bonne politique
sociale quand on la politique du carnet
de chèques
et que penser qu'une bonne politique
sociale se résume à faire des chèques
aux gens c'est être bien méprisant à
l'égard des français
il ya évidemment un sujet de pouvoir
d'achat on a baissé les cotisations
sociales sur le travail pour que le
travail paye plus on a supprimé de
l'autre avec la csg parfaitement assumé
on à la taxe d'habitation qui sera
baissée pour 30 % de son montant pour
80% des français dès le mois d'octobre
et puis il ya des revalorisations qui
sont historiques n ya jamais eu de
revalorisation dans ces montants là ni
du minimum vieillesse une allocation
adulte handicapé ni du complément mode
de garde pour une mère célibataire avec
deux enfants le maximum autorisé la 738
euros de plus par mois depuis le 1er
avril
mais ça on n'en parle pas et je vais
vous dire une ma conviction c'est qu'il
était indispensable si les gens
n'entendent pas s'il était indispensable
de faire cela mais ce qui est encore
plus indispensable et une vraie
politique sociale et des vrais marqueur
d'une bonne politique sociale
c'est ce qu'on a fait dans l'éducation
en divisant par deux le nombre d'élèves
par classe parce que des mômes qui à la
fin du ce1 ne savent pas lire écrire et
compter
on sait que ce sont les décrocheurs
scolaires qu'on a après c'est la police
de sécurité du quotidien dans les
quartiers populaires dans les quartiers
qui sont délaissés par la public c'est
la suppression de la taxe d'habitation
moi je suis quand même amusé quand
j'entends pour être clair les
républicains à l'assemblée nationale
nous dire la main sur le coeur que ils
sont les défenseurs des territoires qui
souffrent et qu'ils votent contre la
suppression de la taxe d'habitation qui
est l'impôt le plus injuste pour les
territoires en difficulté parce que vous
payez plus de taxe d'habitation dans les
territoires en difficulté que dans les
territoires qui vont bien il n'y a pas
beaucoup de cohérence là dedans et donc
une politique sociale c'est certes du
pouvoir d'achat faire en sorte que le
travail paye eux mais c'est aussi toutes
ces politiques de long terme
reconquérir les quartiers populaires par
la police
l'éducation qui est au coeur et toutes
ces mesures là j'étais dans le budget
ils ne les ont pas voté
alors vous êtes contre la politique du
carnet de chèques lucile à une question
à ce sujet et puis parce que bon il ya
quand même des choses qui vont mieux on
parle de retour de la croissance
on a même parlé pour certains de
cagnotte à redistribuer il ya un moment
c'est c'est toujours non pour cette
cagnotte à redistribuer il faut il faut
toujours plus du trésor belleu le john
key à 2200 milliards de dettes dans un
pays qui à 70 milliards de déficit il
faut être tombés sur la tête pour penser
qu'il ya une cagnotte
je suis désolé de le dire comme ça il
n'y a pas de cagnotte dans un pays qui
chaque année un déficit de 70 milliards
et à 2200 milliards de dettes mais la
tragédie que nous laissant la meilleure
mais c'est ce dont nous laissant c'est
ce que nous laissons à nos enfants et il
faut assumer de faire ce choix là c'est
le seul choix responsables les choix que
nous faisons aujourd'hui nous les
faisons pas pour nous faisons par la
génération d'après est notre mission et
m'a la raison à l'engagement qu'elles ni
un politique c'est de faire en sorte que
nous laissions à nos enfants et aux
générations qui viennent un pays dans un
meilleur état que nous l'avons trouvée
et des finances publiques dans un
meilleur état et vous savez pourquoi
parce que moi je n'ai pas envie que
parce que les taux d'intérêt peuvent
demain remontée et bien ce soit les
marchés financiers et les taux d'intérêt
qui dicte les priorités politiques du
gouvernement
si demain les taux remontent et bien le
premier budget de l'état ce avec le
remboursement des intérêts de l'emprunt
moi je veux que le gouvernement de notre
pays puissent faire le choix de mettre
le paquet sur la santé sur l'éducation
sur la police peu importe
mais que ce soit des choix politiques
qui ne soient pas imposées par les
mareyeurs bull une france qui marche
mieux sur ce thème écouter ce que disait
hier olivier faure le nouveau secrétaire
par les secrétaires du ps
la promesse la présidentielle c'était de
mettre la république en marche
le résultat dix mois plus tard c'est que
le gouvernement transforme
progressivement la république en marché
alors que lui répondez vous la
république pour les bons mots ne font
pas un projet politique
donc c'est bien il fait un effet de
tribune il fait un effet de style mais
quid du projet politique écouter le
parti socialiste est en train de vivre
un naufrage j'ai bien écouté ce kadio
didier forillère et sur la révision
constitutionnelle
je vous engage à relire toutes les
contributions de tous les congrès du
parti socialiste depuis 30 ans quels que
soient les sensibilités
ils étaient tous favorables à la baisse
du nombre de parlementaires
ils étaient tous favorables à
l'introduction d'une dose de
proportionnelle pour mieux meilleure
représentativité des minorités
donc ils ont depuis 30 ans écrit dans
tous leurs textes que la réforme que
nous sommes en train de proposer était
la bonne et là parce que c'est nous qui
la propose on on a compris hier qu'il ne
voterait pas qu'il a fait le choix lui
quand on voit ce qu'il a fait le choix à
gauche tout dans l'opposition et le
choix de son parti plutôt que de son
pays
et là c'est une faute voilà pour vous
après les français apprécieront c'est
pas à moi d'apprécier mais je crois que
au regard de l'impérieuse nécessité des
temps que nous vivons et de la situation
que traverse notre pays économique
politique social il est temps de choisir
son pays et de préférer son pays à son
parti et en même temps j'ai envie de
dire pardonnez-moi la formule emmanuel
macron décroche dans les classes
populaires on le voit baromètre après
baromètre on voit qu'il ya quelque chose
qui se crée est ce que vous l'entendez
est ce que vous le comprenez est-ce que
vous l'expliquer et comment est ce que
on remédie à ça comment est ce qu'on
arrive d'ailleurs parlé il ya beaucoup
d'impatience dans les classes populaires
de notre pays il ya beaucoup
d'impatience parce qu'il ya eu beaucoup
de promesses qui n'ont pas été tenues
bas depuis cinq ans seulement mais
depuis de très nombreuses années voire
des décennies et la promesse principale
c'est sans doute la promesse de
protection qui n'a pas été satisfaite et
où l'europe a une part de responsabilité
elle a raté la protection de nos
concitoyens et nos concitoyens et
notamment les plus fragiles ont
considéré qu'elle était plutôt un
facteur de risque supplémentaire pour
eux qu'une chance qu'une protection
ce sera un des débats d'ailleurs
intéressant de l'élection européenne qui
se tiendra l'année prochaine et donc ce
combat là il va pas se gagner sur une
mesure magique ou sur une mesure très
cosmétique se battent cette bataille là
elle se mène dans les quartiers elle
semaine auprès des gens qui sont en
grande précarité
c'est la question de l'est
c'est la question de la sécurité c'est
la question des transports du quotidien
quand on veut défendre les couches
populaires
on soutient la réforme qui va permettre
d'investir 10 millions d'euros par jour
sur les lignes du quotidien parce que ce
sont les classes populaires qui les
empruntent
4 populaire ils sont pas dans les tgv
les tarifs sont trop prohibitif pour eux
et ils font pas par rayon des classes
populaires
il vient de travailler de banlieue des
grandes métropoles dans les
centres-villes et ça ils ont besoin
d'avoir des trains à l'heure avec une
qualité de service meilleur alors je
voulais juste illustré débat parce qu'il
ya aujourd'hui les deux tiers des cadres
qui soutiennent la politique du
gouvernement seulement un peu plus d'un
quart dans les classes populaires
vous dites ça va être un combat qui va
durer longtemps etc
mais est ce qu'il n'ya pas je crois que
olivier faur parler de la france des
marchés mais aussi de la politique de
classe
est ce qu'il n'ya pas c'est pas le
moment de dire là on atteint une rupture
entre les deux et de france je ne crois
pas et on connaît bien les ressorts qui
à gauche comme à droite alors à droite
c'est la france des villes contre la
france des campagnes c'est leur nouveau
credo de manière assez étrange s'il ya
des villes qui se porte bien et puis des
centres villes qui vont moins bien vous
avez de la grande précarité
et puis vous avez des campagnes qui vont
pas bien et puis des campagnes qui vont
très bien parce qu'ils ont fait le choix
de l'innovation qu'elles ont réussi à se
faufiler à trouver leur chemin dans la
modélisation et puis de la même manière
à gauche
ils veulent refaire la lutte des classes
parce que finalement ce sont leurs
vieilles habitudes
c'est ce qu'ils ont toujours connu et
donc il essaie de se raccrocher à
quelque chose qu'ils ont toujours connu
mais aujourd'hui la situation sociale du
pays et la représentation sociale du
pays est très différente et je ne crois
pas que ce soit en agonisant des classes
les unes contre les autres et quoi c'est
là le projet du parti socialiste est
classe populaire quand les classes
moyennes ou l'éclatement haine contre
les classes plus aisées
moi je compte je considère pas que qu'il
faille raisonner par classe ce pays ce
qui le tient
c'est le contrat social qui fait que
notre modèle social a tenu la république
debout depuis l'après guerre et que ce
modèle social qui a été construit en
1945 on est en 2018 il faut l'adapter
ceux qui vous disent qu'on va garder les
choses comme avant que rien n'a changé
qu'il faut surtout que rien ne bouge
sont ceux qui vont enterrer enterrer
notre modèle social et la mobilisation à
la gauche de la gauche on a vu jean luc
mélenchon lancé un appel
à manifester à marseille le 14 avril
françois ruffin et benoît hamon le 5 mai
est ce que ces gens l'oublient l'enfant
il rejoint l'élection présidentielle
parce qu'il n'a jamais digéré de ne pas
être présent au second tour de
l'élection présidentielle
là ils veulent ils se lancent dans la
redite dans la répétition il veut
rejouer l'élection présentielle il a le
sentiment que ça lui a été volé il ya un
problème avec l'élection
ça lui a pas été volé les français se
sont exprimés ne l'ont pas placé au
second tour de l'élection présentielle
ont exprimé un vote clair au second tour
d'élection présidentielle
ainsi alors vous avez parlé de la
situation dans les quartiers
donc c'est aussi un des grands chantiers
d'ailleurs on attend les propositions de
jean louis borloo car il propose un plan
assez fort à 48 milliards d'euros je
sais pas si la somme au frappeur qui
avait rappelé la rigueur budgétaire
mais aujourd'hui trois ministres les
ministres pénicaud de normandie emea
avait prévu un déplacement en
seine-saint-denis pour présenter lancé
les emplois francs et puis ce
déplacement était annulé comment
l'expliquer je crois qu'il ya vraiment
pas de reconquérir le mans c'est juste
reporté il n'y a pas du tout l'intention
de remettre certaines craintes vis-à-vis
de ce qui se passe bien honnêtement je
ne pourrais pas vous dire mais ce que je
sais ce dont je suis certain à ce que je
peux vous confirmer c'est que l'exemple
les emplois francs 1 sont opérationnels
et vont se déployer parce que c'est l'un
des engagements qu'ils avaient pris le
présent la réplique dans le cadre de sa
campagne
c'est un projet auquel nous croyons
beaucoup parce que ça permet d'attacher
les droits non plus à une zone
géographique mais à des jeunes et des
moins jeunes c'est pas que pour les
jeunes c'est aussi pour les personnes
qui sont éloignés d'emplois depuis
longtemps on a eu pendant trente ans des
zones franches qu'est ce qui se passait
on inventait des entreprises qui paient
pas d'impôts dans des quartiers
compliqué et ses entreprises à embaucher
des gens qui habitaient pas le quartier
à nous on a décidé non pas d'attacher
les droits à la zone mais à la personne
et de faire en sorte que les gens qui
habitent dans ces quartiers et bien tout
patron qui les embauchent puissent
bénéficier s'il ya un cdi par exemple de
15000 euros sur trois ans de
défiscaliser risques et jean louis
borloo sera entendu par le chef de
l'état quand il propose donc un plan 48
milliards de jean louis borloo il a pour
lui d'avoir été un des grands ministres
de la ville des 30 dernières années
d'avoir profondément changé le visage de
valenciennes et on sait et les
valenciennois savent ce qu'ils doivent
au maire qu'il ait contrat qu'il était
utile et important d'entendre ce qu'il a
à dire
après je lui dis sur l'anru les crédits
on les a doublées déjà passé de cinq à
dix milliards sur l' agence nationale
pour la rénovation urbaine et donc qu'il
mettra sur la table et je n'en ai pas
connaissance aujourd'hui tout sera
regardée avec intérêt parce que jean
louis borloo
il a une voix particulière il a une voix
qui porte et puis il a des choses à dire
sur la politique de la ville peut dire
qu'elle a une voix qui porte peut-être
une gouaille particulière par rapport à
certains ministres techno qui vous
entourent n'en voudrez vous savez ce
projet ce procès permanent sur le
ministre techno - ce que j'observe c'est
que les transformations se font et que
ce dont on avait dit mais vous savez
sont émises société civile ils ont
permis dans l'éducation dans
l'enseignement supérieur sur le marché
du travail de faire progresser très
rapidement
là où sans doute des ministres très
politique et très aguerris se serait
sans doute casser les dents à laisser la
troisième partie de l'épreuve de vérité
et c'est lucile brio qui va vous poser
la question
[Musique]
cette troisième question elle porte sur
les réformes en cours et à venir
on entend des voix s'élever dans la
majorité sur la réforme
constitutionnelle sur le projet de loi
asile et immigration des gens qui posent
des questions qui s'interroge est-ce que
ça tangue au sein de la majorité ce
qu'il ya des raisons de s'alarmer ce que
là encore il n'ya pas un signal d'arrêt
de la même manière que tout à l'heure
quand il parle d'une seule voix
ce sont des moutons et quand il ya des
sensibilités qui s'expriment c'est la
fronde
il peut y avoir peut-être un juste
milieu entre le panurgisme généralisée
et la fronde permanente et dont vous les
encourager normal non mais il est normal
et sur la question du projet doit asile
immigration gérard que l'on reçoit les
parlementaires depuis des mois il ya des
discussions qui se sont engagés entre
l'exécutif et le parlement depuis des
mois il ya un rapport qui a été remis
par aurélien tâche et je ne parle
montèrent sur cette question là et donc
ce dialogue et la présentation du projet
de loi qui a été fait
il a été travaillé très en amont avec
les parlementaires sur la révision
constitutionnelle de la même manière
qu'eux y ait des sensibilités qui
s'expriment mais c'est parfaitement
légitime
c'est un sujet qui mérite qu'on en
débatte on va pas réformé réviser la
constitution
plusieurs vols dans le quinquennat cas a
priori et donc à partant de là il est
légitime que ça suscite des débats qui
vont avoir lieu à l'assemblée nationale
avant l'été et puis qui reprendront au
sénat à la menthe voilà je vous arrête
un parce que benjamin griveaux vous ne
pouvez pas banalisée comme cela la
parole ce week end et françois bayrou 1
qui alors revendique une part de la
victoire d'emmanuel macro on va
l'écouter ce qui l'attendait on ne sait
plus de proportionnelle 25% par pas 15%
et la fin pour tous les élus du cumul
dans le temps un pas plus de trois
mandats et donc il lui il à son
exposition de son explication à ce qu'il
appelle un tour de passe passe
tout ça a été fait pour essayer de
de séduire le groupe ait l'air du sénat
disons la vérité a de toute façon même à
même d ça ne marchera pas c'est donc que
ça ne marchera pas on a sacrifié une
partie importante de la réforme pour
avoir leur accord est au bout du chemin
on n'aura pas de raccords et on aura
plus de la réforme
c'est pourquoi il va falloir intervenir
de manière décisive pour changer ça
alors le voilà bien remonté sur son
cheval est bien repris le projet que le
présent dans les publics apportés dans
le cadre de la campagne présidentielle
ce projet disait quoi baisser d'environ
30% nombre de parlementaires
c'est ce qu'il ya sur la table donc il
n'y a pas trahison n'a pas escamoter la
promesse il disait pas plus de trois
mandats dans le temps en termes de
cumulus et le projet qui a sur la table
nous n'avons donc pas escamoter la
province et il disait une dose de
proportionnelle dos et c'est vrai que il
n'y avait pas d'engagement sur un
chiffre pendant la campagne pour une
raison simple c'est que c'est un sujet à
manier avec précaution vous le savez qui
doit être à l'écouté des différents
groupes parlementaires et on a entendu
ce qu'il ya des ce qui a été dit à
l'assemblée nationale ce que président
de l'assemblée nationale a porté dans le
projet qu'il a proposé du scrabble dit
le président du sna et on a considéré
que 15% permettait de respecter cette
dose de proportionnelle ça me fait si on
à la baisse de parlementaires à 404
députés parmi ces quatre cent quatre
députés 61 seront élus à la
proportionnelle ça permet aux minorités
ou au groupe peut en parti politique
peut représenter à l'assemblée d'avoir
une meilleure représentation et bien
autant garantir la viabilité d'avoir une
vraie stabilité auxquelles je crois nos
concitoyens sont très attachés parce que
la vème république a des défauts mais si
elle a une qualité c'est de permettre de
dégager des majorités stables qui
permettent de gouverner le pays et donc
c'est dans cet équilibre là que cela
s'est fait en écoutant les uns et les
autres et en respectant les engagements
qu'il n'y a pas de négociation ce sera
pas 25% comme vous voulez on reste à 15
ans fait sur vos actions vous aimez mais
ça n'est pas
on ne modifie pas la constitution avec
des négociations d'arrière boutique
c'est pas vraiment ça bouge pas vraiment
le sujet c'est pas vraiment le sujet
mais en revanche
j'entends aussi que cette réforme de la
révision constitutionnelle ne se limite
pas à ça il ya plein d'autres choses
dedans sur la manière dont va travailler
le parlement et je sais que françois
bayrou qui est un démocrate et qu'il l'a
démontré à de maintes reprise est très
attachée par exemple à ce que le
parlement puisse mieux contrôler
puissent mieux évaluer le travail du
gouvernement et qu' il y a là aussi des
sujets alors il ya les sujets qui sont
intéressants pour les plateaux télé il
ya beaucoup d'eau bien sûr pas tous les
détails et visions et où je suis sûr que
françois bayrou nous apportera sa
sagesse et son expérience de question
précise justement sur le contenu de la
réforme la droite al'inverse 10 30% de
baisse de parlementaires c'est trop
est-ce que ça aussi c'est acté ça
bougera plus est ce que ça peut être
encore 25 et un deuxième volet vous
évoquez le cumul dans le temps le
renouvellement des mandats très
vraisemblablement donc non seulement
vous aviez introduit dans cette mesure
que cette cdm mandat consécutif mais
probablement que le compteur commencera
que maintenant donc elle ne s'appliquera
que dans vingt ou 15 ou 20 ou 25 ans est
ce que c'est vraiment l'esprit macron
mais vous savez l'esprit mâcon c'est à
la fois de transformer essaie de ne pas
braquer en face et les 30%
c'est l'engagement qu'avait pris le
président de la république et il faut et
d'ailleurs le président du sénat
l'anamis dans le débat en disant il faut
qu'il puisse y avoir un sénateur par
département c'est tout quelque chose
qu'elles ont été sensibles et qui est
juste moi je ne saurais pas expliquer
demain qu'on a un département il pas de
se battre pour ça compliqué en termes de
représentation de certains territoires
et donc il n'y a pas de difficultés la
dessus et sur les trois cumulé trois
mandats que sur les nerfs sentant le
danger sur les 30% c'est l'engagement
qu'avait pris le présent dans la pluie
devant les pareil de quattro en douceur
ont tranché c'est sur cet engagement est
sûre et sur le reste
à nouveau on va pouvoir discuter c'est
ça arrive à l'assemblée nationale avant
l'été il y aura un vote avant l'été
le parlement est là pour en débattre
c'est un sujet qui mérite qu'on y passe
du temps et qu'on ait un débat de bonne
qualité ce dont je ne doute pas de nid à
l'assemblée ni au canada edc sur les
sujets où il pourrait y avoir un
référendum est ce que
l'idée est encore dans l'air et ce qui
pourrait être accolé au scrutin des
européennes qui est prévue pour mai 2010
neuf on entend aussi c'était pour
l'instant le débat va s'engager à
l'assemblée nationale donc chaque chose
en son temps on souhaite nous puisse
avancer au maximum et est passé par la
voie parlementaire sur la limitation des
trois mandats dans le temps
est ce que cette règle demain pourrait
s'appliquer au chef de l'état qui est
limité à 2 aujourd'hui vous avez vu là
je n'étais pas moi la suggestion la
réflexion peut être la proposition d'un
très proches comme vous des manuels
macron c'est le sénateur françois
patriat souffler que c'était le 1er
avril et donc à rien n'ayant pas sur le
fait que le président de la république
en france soit limitée à deux mandats
dans le temps mais comme quoi ceux qui
avaient voté cette réforme sans aucun
état d'âme en disant que deux mandats
présidentiels suffisait sont les mêmes
qui parfois considère qu'il faut pouvoir
aller à au delà de trois mandats dans le
cadre de mandats locaux dont je rappelle
que ça ne concerne pas les villes en
dessous de noyen fut 1000 habitants
alors important c'est que nous avons
bien sûr à propos d'élections lucile
évoqué les européennes après il y aura
les municipales benjamin griveaux et je
constate que vos activités de porte
parole du gouvernement ne vous empêche
pas de participer à de multiples
réunions dans la capitale écoutez il se
trouve que avoir été membre du
gouvernement j'ai été élu député de
paris du 3e et 10e arrondissements de
paris donc il m'arrive effectivement
d'être présent dans le débat parisien
mais il m'arrive aussi d'être au delà
des frontières de votre arrondissement
le troisième map un ring vous savez moi
les frontières d'arrondissement jeu
j'essaie d'expliquer que paris doit
dépasser ses propres frontières ça n'est
pas pour recréer les frontières
d'arrondissement à l'intérieur de paris
et donc j'ai été présent sur un débat
qui me tient à coeur qu'est la question
de l'ouverture dominicale et au moins je
le considère qu'il serait sans doute
utile et souhaitable et d'ailleurs les
échanges avec les différentes
associations de commerçants ou les
grands opérateurs de la place de paris
me laisse penser qu'ils sont plutôt
favorables à l'idée que chacun puisse
avoir la liberté d'ouvrir ou pas le
dimanche et que paris est en soi une
zone touristique vous avez d'autres
projets sans avoir première destination
touristique au monde vous avez d'autres
projets comme cela pour lever tout comme
les parlementaires de la république en
marche foisonne de projets pour paris
est ce que les commerçants que vous
rencontrez sont ouverts à l'idée d'avoir
un candidat en marché plutôt pas le
scénario hollywoodien
vous dire une chose il me parle pas de
savoir qui va être candidat à quoi mais
plutôt de est-ce que ça génère du
chiffre d'affaires comment ils vont
pouvoir embaucher des gens et notamment
les petits commerçants parce que vous
avez des problèmes de seuil c'est de ça
dont on parle franchement assez peu de
savoir qui sera candidat tous les corps
la république en marche en 2020 une
alliance avec anne hidalgo s'est
définitivement exclu dans mes écrits si
on raisonne en disant il faut faire des
alliances et des coalitions ça veut dire
qu'on a déjà réglé le problème du projet
les parisiens ça les intéresse pas les
alliances elle n'intéresse pas les
coalitions les arrangements d'appareils
comme on l'a fait depuis très longtemps
dans le pays ce qu'ils veulent savoir
c'est quelle est le projet qui sera
apporté par la république en marche dans
la capitale
et puis au delà de la capitale dans les
grandes métropoles
et puis dans le rapport entre paris et
les territoires voisins entre la seine
saint denis avec le val de marne avec
les hauts-de-seine avec la petite
couronne comment est-ce que ça ça va
tourner c'est ça qui intéresse les
parisiens et le reste franchement assez
peu nous ce qui nous intéresse c'est
aussi ce qui vous intéresse
benjamin griveaux vous avez été élu avec
un score très impressionnant 1 dans
votre arrondissement
emmanuel macron a fait un très gros
score dans la capitale est ce que vous
estimez aujourd'hui qu'effectivement il
doit y avoir une alternance à paris à
l'hôtel de ville
christophe castaner l'a dit moi je
considère la ville a besoin d'un but il
faut juger je demande aux français de
juger l'action du gouvernement à l'issue
du quinquennat je leur demande ça donc
je vais être honnête intellectuellement
je vais pas dire aux français vous
jugerez le quinquennat à l'issue du
quinquennat est jugé le mandat de la
maire de paris qui a été réalisé aux
deux tiers donc il reste un tiers
j'aurais sans doute un avis que
j'exprimerai bien volontiers avant le
mois de mars 2020 sur le bilan de sa
mandature
mais voilà il faut qu'elle puisse aller
au bout de son mandat et ensuite les
parisiens trancheront de l'accord elle a
fait des bonnes choses à paris anne
hidalgo
mais bien sûr vous savez il faut pas
être dans tout blanc ou tout noir et
parce que vous n'êtes pas dans la même
formation politique ont serré que tout
ce qui a été fait a été mal fait moi
j'ai eu l'occasion de dire à maintes
reprises que l'objectif qu'elle a
poursuivi sur la question de la baisse
de la pollution atmosphérique mentalité
le bon objectif j'ai dit que je pense
qu'ils n'étaient pas souhaitables de
rouvrir les voies sur berge
parce que voilà il faut parvenir ce type
de décision mais qu'en revanche sur la
méthode qui avait été employé
eh bien il fallait sans doute avoir une
méthode plus proche des territoires
limitrophes avec de la concertation
comprenait pas d'édition matière
unilatérale dans le centre de paris
sans imaginer que ça ait des
répercussions pour tous les franciliens
voilà il faut paris la frontière
naturelle quel périphérique tombe
il ya donc plusieurs événements
médiatiques cette semaine il est allé
deux prises de parole du chef de l'état
dans deux émissions donc on l'a dit sur
sur tf1 et sur bfm tv et puis il ya la
sortie en librairie du livre de françois
hollande les leçons du pouvoir selon
vous d'un jamais gris vo est ce qu'il ya
une leçon de pouvoir attirer du
quinquennat précédent
sans doute le président hollande at il
été un président en empêcher mais parce
que peut-être par manque de clarté dans
le projet politique qu'il a présentée
dans le cadre de l'élection
présidentielle n'a t-il pas su maintenir
une majorité autour de ce projet parce
que le projet a changé et quand vous
mettez en place un projet politique sur
lequel vous n'avez pas été élu que ça
suscite
interrogations parfois de la fronde dans
votre propre camp et bien fait que vous
avez une présence empêcher donc eu de la
clarté de l'autorité aussi façade
éventuellement on a compris que vous les
et volt et de les utiliser le mot tout à
l'heure une question d' empêchement une
question d' empêchement son empêchement
mais voilà moi je vais lire les de son
pouvoir si apprécié à présent de la
république mais ils ont relâché les
régresser il n'a pas écouté vous pourrez
aussi acheter le livre en librairie
tous ses proches disent de toute façon
il n'a qu'un rêve
françois hollande c'est revenir vous
vous lui donnez une chance de revenir
dans le jeu politique a laissé les
français sont dans ce domaine là et en
matière d'addiction les seuls juges
merci beaucoup benjamin griveaux d'avoir
été avec nous aujourd'hui merci beaucoup
d'avoir réagir aux nombreux sujets
d'actualité effectivement qui interpelle
le gouvernement merci à lucie merci marc
la semaine prochaine c'est eric ciotti
de lutte ouvrière 2 les républicains je
veux m'excuser mois de heller qui sera
notre invité et qui rit pourra taper à
coeur joie sur le projet de gérard
collomb donc vous avez défendu son
projet doit bonsoir à tous à la semaine
prochaine pour ça
[Musique]